Heidi Klum is vying for a spot in the
Spice Girls but is her fellow AGT judge
Mel B be replaced by Queen Latifah Plus
why we are already obsessed with
Celebrity Big Brother hello my eyeballs
are about to fall out because I've been
watching so much TV this week Celebrity
Big Brother premiered and I'm already
addicted
I'm also binging queer eye on Netflix
and have more from the fab 5 in just a
few but first we got to talk about how
you clue because she stepped out looking
like a showgirl at the amfAR gala last
night and looking shining shimmering
splendid it appears she may be plying
her chance to finally be a sixth member
of the Spice Girls the group stirred up
talk of a reunion tour after all five
members got together recently for this
epic photo I mean people went nuts and
if a tour is happening
Heidi tells us she's there I told think
all of us can agree we're hoping they'll
be and the rest of the girl spice up our
lives on a tour but what about scary
spices fate on America's Got Talent
there are rumors that a GT judge is so
difficult on set that producers want to
replace her with Queen Latifah and
here's what Heidi had to say about that
I have no idea I have no idea I hope
she's going to be sitting next to me
again I love her dearly but I really
don't know they keep everything very
much hush this is going to be my sixth
year I think on America's Got Talent
I
a week people I got hired in my very
first year literally so you never know
what happened now this wouldn't be the
first AGT shake-up of course last season
Tyra Banks replaced Nick Cannon as a
judge we'll soon find out about Mel B
because judges auditions begin in about
five weeks meanwhile the first season of
Celebrity Big Brother in the u.s. is
officially underway and last night's
premiere was watched by over seven
million people making it the
most-watched show of the night it's no
surprise because it was ridiculously
entertaining where else can you get mark
McGrath Big Time Rush's james maslow
Brandi Glanville and a bunch of other
celebs all stuck in a house together and
a girl Alliance is already being formed
with American Pie Shannon Elizabeth and
TVs favorite villain Omarosa Omarosa
proved last night she came to win and
girl knows how to play the game play her
part and of course play up the cameras
here's what she said about her
surprisingly simple strategy to win I
come into the Big Brother house with a
ton of baggage and so my strategy is
simply this to have a really good time
and to win the game being I gotta say
Omarosa may seem tough but she might be
softer than we think
The Apprentice villain broke down in the
Celebrity Big Brother backyard about her
time working for Donald Trump in the
White House in this bombshell clip from
tonight's episode like I was a haunted
by tweet everything
like what is equal to tweet next does
anybody say to him what are you doing I
mean I tried to be that person and then
all the people around him and to have to
be it that airs tonight on CBS and we'll
be bringing you guys exclusive Celebrity
Big Brother content every week and
breaking down everything you need to
know about the show
our first recap show premieres on
Wednesday next week so be on the lookout
for it all right
yesterday I sat down with the cast of
the new queer I
the show has returned to Netflix with a
new fat 5 and I turn the tables on the
fellas to get to know them better and
hit them with a fab 5 Fast Five who is
your celebrity crush that was mine but
you totally deserve because you've been
a very big huge support of him for a
long time I know some really bad you
need celebrities yeah that's a child it
was definitely Mario Lopez okay just
fine right what is your must-have
accessory seekers yeah an amazing bomber
jacket a blow dryer literally all mine
I'm not even gay Bob or Jackie what's
one thing we'd be surprised to find in
your music library believe you know
she's the best ever
I know it's not doesn't surprise me like
dude dizzy chicks are like Martina
McBride okay jay-z jay-z okay that
wouldn't surprise you okay
I don't know like all my music is pretty
like you look at me you know what I'm
listening actually there is I love that
Mandisa like that can like know is like
a cute song I say this though I have now
been exploring a lot of queer artists
and there's a lot of queer artists that
are coming up that are just like
representing for the LGBTQ community and
I want people to go explore and find
them because they are ready to hit the
mainstream what's your worst habit or
biggest guilty pleasure coffee okay talk
about controlling things controlling
thing but that is not your that is your
biggest strength yeah okay this one can
literally be asleep in the car in the
moment the camera comes on alright
what's the best piece of advice you guys
have for anyone trying to improve their
lives
BOC yeah yeah like the best version of
yourself so I'm like happiness is an
inside job
like it's like she's inside yeah and be
curious don't like stifle yourself be
curious about the world it's okay yes I
was gonna say be a student and always
want to learn and watch daily penny
what's the daily Danny that will improve
your life here's that $20 I promise yeah
Jess you're that watch the daily Deni I
promise I did not tell him to say that
but they're not wrong are you guys can
binge all eight episodes of queer eye on
Netflix and of course watch new episodes
of the daily Denny here just make sure
you're subscribed to e t--'s channel and
have your notifications turned on poll
at this playlist and I'll see you guys
tomorrow because it's new use it Friday
you